IBM maybe at another turning point in
its storied history in October the
company announced it was buying the
cloud software provider Red Hat for
thirty four billion dollars in its
biggest tech deal ever IBM is also
investing 1 billion dollars in
initiatives like apprenticeships to
train workers for what it calls new
collar jobs IBM president and CEO Ginni
Rometty coined the term for workers who
have technology skills but not a
four-year degree Ginni Rometty joins us
now great to have you at the good
morning so much to discuss yes you know
there's been so much focus on how AI and
automation are changing the workforce
yes talk about what these new collar
jobs are that you're trying to add to
address that yeah I think it really gets
it one of the biggest issues of our time
because these new technologies are great
they're gonna solve many problems I've
been on the show before to talk about
healthcare but they also create a big
digital divide almost a haves and
have-nots and so people often talk about
jobs being removed by AI I really think
of it as jobs are gonna be a hundred
percent changed by AI so each of us is
gonna work with AI in some way of doing
our job but it does mean for this world
you can't have a hundred percent of all
jobs having to have a university degree
or just think about the amount of
retraining that has to go on out there
so we came up with this concept of new
collar meaning it's not white collar
it's not blue collar it's a really
positive thing to have a set of skills
and not necessarily has to be
credentials skills that you can work
with these technologies so new collar so
not white not blue a new collar job and
it really is to go aim at sets of kids
are you know around the world and
retraining of adults so that they can
participate can make a great wage and
what's economy and what specifically are
these skill sets yeah well so think of
it as you could be anything that you
interact your call center agent and you
interact with technology to do your job
or on the other hand if you're an IBM
you could be a cyber analyst or you
could be an app developer a cloud
programmer we have some great examples
we I've just had a graduating class we
have both apprenticeships as a new form
of Education and something a brand new
set of public high schools called
pathway to technology
I should say it's a brand new program
I'm not a brand new set of schools it's
take public high schools New York
Community College and think of it as a
six year high school and these are
really aimed at they're called p-tech
pathway to technology early college high
school so six years you get a high
school degree and you get your associate
degree and you can go take a job in they
call stem science technology engineering
math related jobs and there's a bit of a
formula it is business gives the school
it helps them with a curriculum mentors
internships and we've got 550 companies
helping along with IBM all over this
country right now it feels like you're
creating an education system here in one
sense in all these different programs
but then also in a way it sort of feels
like old fashioned vocational training
yeah there's a very big difference you
know because if you think about
vocational training often that was - by
the way if you go look at vocational
schools graduations it's very low
graduation rate on vocational schools
and community colleges this is 500 times
and so it is not a separate school it is
a normal high school six-year curriculum
like I said and when the kids come out
they're able to take a job across almost
any company in any kind of digitally
related field so right now the in the
United States 11 states there is 120
schools soon to be 200 of these schools
and a pipeline of 125,000 children
coming through kids young adults coming
on through and we're expanding actually
13 other countries in fact actually I
think today by this time Frances signed
France Ireland and Columbia were this
week and so the idea is when the kids
come out and they're able to jump right
in and let me give you a couple quick
examples the first school was Brooklyn
not too far from here this is now six
years ago
Gabriel Rosa young man who at age 14
hacked the school's computers and
instead of being dismissed you know a
really smart principal said let me try
something here put this kid in this
program and by age 16 he'd actually
graduated high school and his associates
degree and then now works for us and by
the way is a great great app developer
here and so that's
the idea so you can put them in just
about any field Jenny let me art Lasky
about the larger economic picture when
you and I spoke last you were advocating
for the tax cut that ultimately was
approved by the Congress the president's
tax cut that was corporate tax cuts then
you said would cause would create jobs
and economic growth
what is IBM done with some of the tax
savings well it actually for IBM turns
out to be a tax headwind so but we were
a strong supporter of it because for the
long run it is really the right thing to
do but even in this sort of envelope and
where the world is right now we still
see great opportunity out there and as I
said what we have done we have made a
commitment around helping retrain a
hundred thousand people in this economy
for jobs both at IBM and elsewhere that
can actually work in this new era
all right Ginni Rometty thank you so
much for being here with us life it